[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our question and answer program
I'm CA Murray and it is my privilege and
my pleasure to greet you this day and we
are so very very glad that you've joined
us for what is one of our favorite
programs I'm in the company of my friend
and colleague in Ministry Pastor David
Salazar pastor always good to have you
here thank you Pastor it's a blessing to
share this time with you as well amen
and amen one of our favorite programs
and we hope one of yours also we are
getting questions from all over the
world uh and it it pleases us to know
amen that we're reaching just about
every inhabited continent of the world
we're getting questions from and we're
very very glad to get them and of course
equally glad to answer them uh from the
word of God and of course that is a
problem promise that we make to you each
and every time we open this show and
that is that our answers will come from
the word of God if an answer can be
found in the word of God we will get it
from the word of God and give you the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth amen so help us God as we uh
you know we want truth in these last
days and we want the truth of God to be
shared in these last days and that's
what we promise to give you should you
want to be part of this program if you
have a question a thought a comment
something that is troubling you please
send your questions to
TV at some
tv.org that's TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we will get to your
questions just as soon as we can
our list of questions is is growing in
English and in Spanish so it takes us a
little while to get to all of the
questions but we promise you that we
will do so
um so hold us hold on have a little
faith we're going to get to your
questions just as soon as we can and it
will be from the word of God Pastor if
you would open up with prayer we will
start today's program and see how far we
get thank you let's pray
Heavenly Father we are thankful once
again to come before you and to seek
your Holy Spirit to lead us into all
truth to bring to our minds and to our
membranes the thing that you have said
and allow us to be vessels in your work
to share with others the truths that are
found in scripture I pray that you will
lead us now and also be with those that
are listening that are watching may your
spirit be with them and guide them to
all truth with pray in Jesus holy name
amen amen and amen all right uh we have
one additional question that we did not
uh get to and last we were together this
is from Rennie who writes from
Washington State
his question is
in Ephesians chapter 4 verse 30 and I
suspect we ought to turn there so that
we have Ephesians 4 30. we read about
the Holy Spirit as our seal unto the day
of redemption
in Revelation chapter 7 verse 3 the
angel said hurt not the sea nor the
trees till we have sealed the Servants
of God in their foreheads here's my
question
in Ephesians unto the day of redemption
does not does this mean until Jesus
comes English is my second language that
is why I'm asking I wish you would have
told us what his first language was yes
I'm just curious to know right I just
want to make sure because I have been
listening to your show and understand
that one can lose their salvation if
they are not walking in the spirit thank
you very much looking forward to your
answer and hearing from you very soon
it is true that we do not believe once
saved always saved you can lose your
salvation if you do not continue with
Jesus Christ only those who finish the
race receive the prize not to those who
drop in and drop out or fall by the
wayside uh you've got to finish the race
to get the prize so that says to me that
you you can lose your salvation
absolutely
um so we know that so
um what does it mean now for us to be
sealed unto the day of redemption that's
a wonderful question pastor and like you
said let's read there in Ephesians
chapter 4 verse 30. uh Paul is speaking
it to the Ephesians and says the
following and believe not the holy
spirit of God I believe not the holy
spirit of God whereby ye are sealed unto
the day of redemption so he's
here Paul is speaking and telling us
that we can grieve the Holy Spirit
which is the agency that seals us until
the Redemption until the day we are
redeemed so I guess part of the question
he has is that the word Redemption here
means the second coming of Jesus
and I think that
this will be answered by the we can
answer this with uh another text that is
found in the Book of Luke
chapter 21.
uh for some people I know and probably
this is what our friend Rennie has
listened or heard in the past you know
once you are saved do you accept Jesus
you're redeemed and so does that really
mean and I think they have to be we have
to be careful how we use that word
redeemed and what exactly means let's
just look briefly with us with me here
in in Luke 21 and I'm sorry what I went
to Matthew for some reason but Luke 21
verse 23 I'm 25 to 28.
it says the following Christ is speaking
here of the events that are going to
happen and it says and there shall be
signs in the Sun and in the moon and the
stars and upon the Earth the stress of
nations with perplexity the Sea and the
Y and the waves roaring man's Hearts
failing them for fear and for looking
after those things which are coming on
the earth for the powers of the heavens
shall be shaken and then shall they see
the son of man coming in the cloud with
power and great glory and when these
things begin to come to pass then look
up and lift up your heads for your your
Redemption draweth nigh so here we see
that Christ himself is using the word
Redemption
in the sense of
the Deliverance the ultimate Deliverance
of
this earth and the scene of this earth
when he is coming the clouds then
Redemption has drawn nigh that is the
end result that full Redemption that
full uh freedom of sin where you're
lives or lives or our bodies will change
into our Incorruptible when we will see
this son of God in coming the class of
Glory that is when the Redemption it's
fully fulfilled so that day redemption
that Paul is speaking of that the Holy
Spirit seals until that day is
definitely speaking to that second
coming of Christ yes you know yes the
the Christ coming equals the Drawing
Near of redemption uh he's coming to
bring Redemption so he's saying look up
because your Redemption is coming
towards you the the Greek word for
Redemption is
which means to set apart to set a
liberty or to free from uh all of those
are consonants in that term so when
Christ comes we will be freed from the
presence and power of sin we will be
redeemed so
um it is the answer to his question is
yes that the second coming of the Lord
is is the ultimate Act of redemption
absolutely uh he he has called us and we
are actually in the process of being
redeemed even now right no absolutely
yeah uh we are being freed from sin we
are gaining Victory through Grace and
Faith in the Holy Spirit but the
ultimate Redemptive act will be the
second coming of Christ absolutely which
takes us out of the sinful world and
takes us to a world of of no sin so he
is right about that amen I I think that
even Paul Pastor you know just to press
this point even clearer or at least
making sure that we're not speaking out
of terms here you know in in Romans 8 23
or 28 22 and 23 uh Paul speaks of what's
happening on the earth and the nature
itself it says therefore we know that
the whole creation grownness with
travailis and live in pain together
until now and not only they but
ourselves also which have the first
fruits of the spirit even or we
ourselves growing within ourselves
waiting for the adoption to wit the
Redemption of our body in other words
he's speaking of his own experience too
and saying you know we our bodies are
decaying our bodies are you know like
the nature itself is grown in is feeling
in pain because of sin so our Redemption
the Redemption the full Redemption will
be when our bodies when we'll be you
know transformed to receive that
immortality that new body that the Lord
promises to those that will see his
coming so it will be ultimately that
Redemption will be in that freedom that
will receive you know from your sin so I
think that makes it very clear from the
Bible what Redemption means in in that
falseness of of the sense but does it
start now yes it does I mean her
Redemption starts with our salvation
with our you know our justification so
it is probably important
I I looked this up in the Amplified
Bible
um you know it's funny when when you're
a pastor and people want to give you a
Christmas gift for a birthday gift for
an anniversary gift or present uh oh
let's give him a Bible
something along giving here in Ministry
the more bottles you pick up I got about
40 Bible and it's I've got all these
Bibles lined up in my in my study and of
course you open up your your iPad and
you got all those Bibles right there I
know got so many bibles right there so I
looked out of an amplified the Amplified
uses this last term Redemption as the
final deliverance from the consequence
of sin I like that yes and and I like
that also because it kind of explains
what's happening there we will be
delivered from the consequences of sin
of course the wages of sin is that is
death right so we will be delivered from
that uh on that day when death no longer
has a hold over the redeemed amen of God
Amen so I think this is a good answer to
our friend rainy and obviously Pastor
the the aspect is you know the Lord has
promised us we will be redeemed and the
full Redemption will come when he
arrives in the Clouds Of Glory
just write us back and let us know what
your first language is I'm just I'm just
curious amen I would love to know that
right where you're from right amen for
that
so we have another question Pastor the
next question comes to us from B Quang
and uh I don't know where he's from but
obviously he seems from his email must
be from some place not in the Western
World which we also would love to have
the knowledge where he's from but let's
see here the question here is a question
found in Matthew 22 verse 30.
and the question is what does it mean
when Jesus says we shall be as angels
that's the question in Matthew 23 22 30.
does it mean we no longer relate to each
other as father mother daughter son Etc
and then I like how he ends his
his uh question by saying Jesus
described me in verse 29.
so let's read actually Matthew 22 29 and
30 because I like how he actually speaks
of himself as Jesus referring to him in
verse 29 Pastor are you there I am
indeed thank you please Matthew 29 22 29
beginning of verse 29 I'm reading from
New King James
Jesus answered and said to them you are
mistaken not knowing the scriptures nor
the power of God for in the resurrection
they neither marry nor are given in
marriage but are like the angels of God
in heaven
and you want 31 also no well that's why
he just said 30 but okay you can go okay
31 as well okay but concerning the
resurrection of the Dead have you not
read what was spoken of
spoken to you by God saying I am the god
of Abraham the god of Isaac and the god
of Jacob God is not the god of the dead
but of the living amen so the the the
text begins to explain itself right in
the context of what you're reading right
right right and like you know he's
mentioning you know and like I said I
think I like how he approaches himself
says the Lord described me in verse 29
as he said you know you you air not
knowing the scriptures not the power of
God so please be Juan is a very humble
guy yeah you know yes asking and we are
definitely uh like like you in that
sense we made mistakes by not knowing
the power of God or not knowing the
scriptures now the answer there it's as
you mentioned is it kind of within the
same context and it's important to
understand that the question that was
done
by this group of Sadducees who did not
believe in Resurrection who did not
believe that there was going to be life
after you know dying and of course
judgment they didn't believe in none of
that they just believed that we only had
one chance on Earth and that was it and
they will mock the idea of resurrection
and they try to use Jesus to kind of you
know accuse him or trying to figure out
how he could
make sense of their
thoughts of how Resurrection did make
sense by portraying any scenario of a
man marrying many you know or a woman
I'm sorry marrying several Brothers as
they had no children and so whose why
would she be off in the resurrection
that was kind of the trick question
about what they did so Christ answers to
them in a way that he didn't speculate
or try to give them uh you know rebuke
their thinking of you know how are you
you know thinking of this scenario that
is very impossible or whatever he's
actually trying to tell them listen your
mistake is in not believing in the power
of God to give life again you resurrect
and then he says In Heaven There is no
marriage or not given in marriage
there's not this need anymore there is
he just lives that will be like Angels
you know but I have to say something you
know Christ or actually the Apostle John
in John First John 3 2
he says something there he says vivola
beloved now we are the sons of God and
it do not yet appear what we shall be
but we know that when he shall appear we
shall be like him for we shall see him
as he is so even the Apostle John speaks
that we will be like Jesus in heaven so
when Jesus says we'll be like angels and
then the Apostle John says that we're
going to be like Jesus or like him it
sort of gives us an idea of the
experience more than the you know the
fine details of life itself in heaven I
think that it's it's hard for us to
start speculating or trying to say you
know will I not see my brother or sister
as a as a brother and sister will I no
longer have that bond anymore you know I
think that that is taking a little more
The Words of Christ and she's just
better to accept him as he says you know
we'll be experience is going to be
different you know per se you know I I
want to sort of go around about the barn
to get to some point I like what what
you said I agree wholeheartedly when
you're reading the book of first and
second Corinthians yes you've got to
read it given the understanding that
Paul is writing to a church in trouble
right you know so a lot of the things he
says that sound like Commendation are
really not he's telling you've got to
stop this stuff you know because you're
the Corinthians is a church in trouble
they've got a number of problems that
he's addressing right so you've got to
look at the whole book in that context
the
Bible here in Matthew gives you the
context by what it says in the first
verses of this particular section the
same day the Sadducees who say there is
no erection Resurrection came to him and
asked him so this is not a Bible study
this is an entrapment meeting yes
exactly they're trying to find something
to hang on him yeah so they invent this
story because they're trying to find
evidence you know against his
messiahship right they don't believe in
him they don't accept him so they're
trying to dig up stuff to try to hang
him with it yes exactly so uh they they
they
concoct this story
and Christ is dealing directly with the
audience that he's talking to right he's
not setting a precedent for the whole
church for the whole world for all time
he is trying to get these guys to
understand something right about this
story that they put which is
disingenuous because they don't believe
in a resurrection exactly you know the
Bible's told you they don't buy the
resurrection so why are you giving me
this story this as my mother would say
song and dance about a resurrection
experience that you don't believe in so
we know they're trying to get him
they're out to get him entrance like you
said so Christ says something to them he
he he sort of cuts them off you don't
know what you're talking about you don't
know about the resurrection obviously
you're not familiar with the scriptures
on this subject we're going to be like
Angels uh these things are not going to
happen and this scenario that you have
just put to me will make no sense in
heaven because this is not how Heaven
functions on this wise in this sense not
just for everything so I'm glad you
brought that point out he's dealing with
a specific case and a specific charge
that's put to him he is not setting down
a precedent for all people for all times
concerning everything that's going to
happen in heaven amen and that's
important because we need to just
sometimes limit what to what the
scripture says and not speculate beyond
that like I said you know if he says
that we will be like Angels or we'll be
like him it just gives us an idea that
our existence or experience would be
enhance much better than we can we can
expect now will relationships that are
made on Earth that are sanctioned by the
Lord here on Earth be broken it doesn't
make sense it wouldn't make sense you
know my my siblings my my reason for my
parents will only be better if we're in
heaven even better you know and and
there is that aspect now how exactly
would it be will it be you know those
details the Lord says look you're airing
because you don't know you know the
scriptures you ignore the power of God
we are talking based on what we know
here and trying to make a whole argument
or a Doctrine on something that we only
can see it with our limited eyes of what
life in heaven is like is really not our
place to do you know we're not to do
that and so uh Pastor you're right I
believe that is is important just to
limit ourselves to that aspect and know
that God will in due time in heaven
reveal to us what details will be for
experiences with families you know I
don't know exactly you know but that's
the Lord's plan whatever it is it's
going to be better than what we have
absolutely absolutely Christ is being
hit with with a double barrel thing here
if you go back to
um Matthew 22 go back to verse 15. the
Pharisees are also on his case you know
you got the Pharisees and scribes who
are not best buddies by any stretch but
they were United in their dislike in
history of Jesus so look at verse 15.
then the Pharisees went and plotted how
they might entangle him in his talk so
this is a context where everything that
happens throughout the rest of the
chapter they're trying to trap him
they're trying to find something to use
against him the Pharisees take their
shot with taxes and then the Sadducees
take their shot with marriage and and
think and they're both trying they're
not trying to learn they're not trying
to to to be edified they're trying to
trap him and catch him in his own words
often you know very often Pastor you
you're mentioning something that happens
a lot
people we like to use scripture to bring
or or use scenarios to question how the
Lord will deal with certain things you
know and the scenarios
are very articulated very carefully
thought out to bring
question or a doubt to what the Lord has
said or how the other has revealed and
we are to be cautious of trying to
pursue answers to many things that the
scripture has not really said and we
have seen this happen within our church
within those Christians that are holding
to the truth where they receive
some sort of
I don't know a message or a presentation
by somebody questioning or adding to
things that are in the scriptures or
putting in scenarios that you know for
example what's the nature of the Holy
Spirit you know what is it a man is a
woman that kind of thing you know things
that are really not necessary for us to
know or answer this time we are not able
to understand uh though I had a question
recently about you know uh the you know
how did God existed you know and and I'm
telling like the Lord does not we cannot
understand anything but you know because
we have only a beginning and an end in
our minds or our brains only allow us to
understand things from beginning to end
God says I'm Eternal right I've been
here forever so that we cannot
understand it's just best not to try to
answer so some things like like you know
specifically how in heaven will be IV
would I have uh you know a wife will I
be able to have children those two
questions that a lot of times go along
with this question can be or it can be
implanted by people who are trying to
twist the scriptures because a lot of
times I believe sincere folks you know
come to these questions based on those
that mock the Bible or mock the idea of
of of Heaven you know on the life in
heaven so it's important that we keep
this in mind as we approach these
scenarios or questions in the Bible as
well and that's what we're dealing with
here if you go down to verse 34 I just
find this so fascinating
um we know this is a time of testing
verse 34 but when the Pharisees heard
that he had silenced the Sadducees you
know wow now they they find us a lawyer
the Scribe he's going to take a shot you
know
the Pharisees didn't do it the Sadducees
didn't do it so now they find this
attorney this abogado you know uh he's
going to take a shot so he he has his
question now yeah yeah
um so so basically they're spending
their time trying to pick at him and
trying to get uh stuff on him you know
to use a colloquialism
um Pharisees try verse 15 Saturday Shri
verse 23 uh scribes and lawyers try at
verse 34. so everybody's trying to get a
little piece of him absolutely none of
them succeed because truth always wins
out but you see the context for this
this this question and the context for
his answer uh he's not trying to set
precedent he's not trying to set
biblical Doctrine for everybody he's
dealing with people who don't believe
who are challenging him and who who will
not really receive what he's going to
say anyway he's not casting his Pearls
Before Swine I know pastor and you know
there is another this this ex story is
actually a little bit more expounded in
Luke chapter 20. and I would like to
really read these couple of verses that
sort of helps us understand the emphasis
of Christ in in answering this man in
this matter it says there in verse 34
remember this is the same story the same
scenario that they are coming just look
it's just telling it with a little more
details or perhaps giving us a little
more details on why Christ answered the
way he did it says they're in verse 34
and Jesus answering said unto them the
children of this world marry and are
given in marriage
but they which shall be accounted worthy
to obtain that world and the
resurrection from the death neither Mary
nor given in marriage so you see your is
this is this a saying then that we
should never be married that's not what
he's trying to say at all his idea is
those who are
seeking to the lustful things
you know those are seeking to
get married for whatever reason get
divorced get married again continue in a
life of fulfilling just a lustfulness
need on their bodies it's really the
problem and says children of this world
are not into that you know I mean
children of those that are looking are
not looking to that they are interested
in a relationship with Christ and
they're gonna work to develop the true
love because you know when somebody uh
and you know when you just get married
in that divorce you haven't developed
that love of Christ now obviously
there's a receptions to the rule I mean
if there's adultery or something like
that's a different story but
when somebody just wants to give up on
somebody else there's there's they
haven't realized that God calls us to
have a love true love for one another
yeah and this is where Christ is trying
to point the you know make the point the
issue here is what's in your heart as in
your heart just
you know marrying and then moving on to
the next person and then you know
continue like that or is it really
trying you're trying to have a
relationship with Christ so you can have
a blessed home life a blessed marriage
in your home so unfortunately time is
leaving
very fastly but I believe that as we can
you know study scripture and we can read
more scripture realize that Christ his
emphasis is not in saying marriage is
wrong or we're not to be married but
it's really mainly speaking to those
that are seeking only for the temporal
things you know for the heart that you
know just fulfilling their last of the
flesh I believe God is calling us to a
different experience Pastor any last
words and before we oh nope just goodbye
and God bless you thank you again
thank you
[Music]
foreign